JOME FROM LDOVA, U.S.
SEARY OF SNT
BL
NING US.KEHO HOSPITALS,
TARGETING DRINKING W, GR
I UNDERSTAND THE U.S. DOEST
EAN
BUT IT SEEMS
IMPLEMENTEDMM
HT NOW IS VANC THAT THE LINE
NOT KE ENOUGH TO
O ARE
SAYING WHY HAS
DIRECTLY INTERVENED TO SAVE THEM
JAKEH NATO
PEAN UNION PTN
WOON, AMONG OTHER , INCREASINGH
ALREED
TH ACT THAT ARE HAVIN
CRIPPLING EFFECTTHE RUSSIAN L AS
OUIEING GETTING THEM EN ASSISTCF
WE'VEOT
TO DATE AND THAT HAS BEE
VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS
C
HAS, THELI RE HAS ANOV
DING THINGDOSTLY ACOURAGEOUS UK.
I THINK WE
O LAST SOME .ST BATTLE IS NOTNN
OF THE UKRAINIANE.ONO LOSE.
LE HAV
THEMSELVES TO BE
VLADIMIRINR RUSSIA
OUE SO
MEWHFERING IS
IT'S TERRIBLE.WIO ARE
M UKRAINE WHHA
BEEND TO
CHIGHBORS
MN UKRAINHT.
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHINGCAN TOINGL
GO ON FOR A
WHILE.
THTED. POI
THEY ARE.
EYE
BUT TH H
AS QUICKEU HAS O
SANCS AGAINSTHN E , THE NATIONAT
CO THEIR FAMILIES, THE
THE  HASS OFOIIOL RK ON THE IRA.
WH EVERYTHING WE
NOW?
SPEAKER LOS SHE'
OFF ALL IMPORTS
SANCTIONS EVERY DA DOING
ITN COORDINATION
OR THE OTHER, WE'RE CLOSINGWHE
WITH TREOF THE CABINET OEXACE S
W TALKING TO OPARTNERS ANDS K I
OFOF RUSSIAN
WHILE MATHERE ISSTILL AN APPROPL
OIL ON WORLDTS DISCUSSION
ASSP>> THES RUOU
NO-FLY ZONTIINTO DIRECT MILITARE
C
Y THS. UKRAINE THELAS
>> SO WE ARE WITPOAS WE SPEAK TO
BACKFILL ATHY
PROVIDE TO THE UKRAINIANS. SUPPS
LYO  CAN
WE'RE ACTIVELYUT
THATIGHT N.
IERMINAL URT IS A
INVEAR
CRIMES.
THU.S. 'ESS IT'IME TO ATTACK.
THE STATE DEPAME
WHIA STEP.THE U.S. SEET S COMM
>> JAK SEEN VERY REPORTS OF DELD
E SEEN VEREDIBLE REPORTS
T E OFERAPONS.
RITL G D
MAKING SURE THATLE
THE APPROPRIATE ORNI
ANNS INVESTIGATE
ARE BEING ITTED, T
PPATEVER TY' DOING.
THESE RYDID WE'R
DOCUER>> WESTENTNCGGESTS
YOU TALKED TO THE CHINESTED, QU
TIAN
CHINA IS THAT, ARE THTION SOVER,
I SPENDS ABOUT A
PHONE  MCON MINISTER, AND
ONE OF THEI AID BE RA
COMMITTED THISN RAIN CHINA SS T
HEA PERMANENT ME
RESPONSIBILITY OF KEEPING PEROU
RE
STYOU HAVE ONE OF ITRMANEN
S ATERY
PRINCIPLE.
T
ERSAID IN THE
STANDP AN
VOICE
1 IES IN THE.N
CACONDEMN IA
GAINST UKRAINE AND
MATS HEARD.AINE.E  CHI
REFUGEES HADY FLEDPE THEY'LL D>L
MI.
U.AYT RE THIS  ILAND
YESTERDAY..SIAN D IF S
>> OF COURSE.
WE'LL LOOK AT THAT.
ION.RE GOINGN SHORTLY,cCRE THENE
WE MET WITH MANYN HIS.
AND DR O FLEE.
FIRST OF ALL,  SUPPORT THE T
E IMMEDIATE
BURDEN OF TAKING